uipath is a leading robotic process
automation tool built for both business
and i.t
more than 200 000 developers are working
on uipath
hey everyone i welcome you all to this
session
in this session we will learn about ui
path
let's look at today's agenda we shall
begin with
understanding what is uipath after that
we shall see the key features of ui path
then we shall see the different
components of ui path
and understand the architecture of ui
path which layers are present and what
role they play in the architecture
post that we will look at some of the
applications of uipath
as to how ui path is used in different
fields
and after that we shall see the benefits
of uipath
then top companies hiring uipath
developers
followed by salary trends for ui part
developers
finally we will look at a hands-on demo
to automate a task using uipath
but before we begin make sure you have
subscribed to our youtube channel and
clicked on the bell like
so you never miss an update from simply
learn
so without wasting any further time
let's get started
with what is ui path
uipath is a robotic process automation
tool for large-scale end-to-end
automation
for an accelerated business change it
provides solution for business to
automate routine office activities
it uses a variety of methods to
transform tedious tasks into automated
process
daniel dines and marius tirka romanian
entrepreneurs
founded uipath in bucharest in 2005.
the first uipath desktop automation
product line was launched in 2013
giving business rpa tools to automate
manual and repetitive back-office tasks
let's look at the features of uipath
drag and drop workflow the user of
uipath will develop visual process steps
by dragging and dropping related tasks
onto the graphical workspace
then with the user interface properties
they can transform those process steps
into a visual workflow
users may also use the recorder wizard
in the uipath tool to build
web based or application workflows the
next feature is record and playback
the user can use this function to record
actions and transform them into
automated process series
ui path has the following types of
recording options
basic recording it focuses on automating
single task and is commonly used to
develop each activity's complete
selector
desktop recording it can be used for a
variety of actions
as well as actions development web
recording
it is a common tool for viewing and
recording web page activities
citrix recording it is very widely used
for recording stuff like pictures and
virtualized environment automation
next we have inbuilt activities in
uipath
uipath comes with over 300 built-in
activities covering a wide range of
process automation and application
integration design tasks
these activities are found in activities
pane which covers most design tasks such
as data extraction data entry and
automation
next we have advanced scraping options
scraping data from web pages and
applications
is easier with ui path screen scraping
furthermore
the data screen scraping wizard helps in
scraping of data with a repetitive
structure
scraping solution works flawlessly with
any program
including.net java flash pdf legacy and
sap
next we have high security and
robustness we can create super smart
durable robots with ui path
with a simple visual canvas everyone in
the company can use bots
ui path offers high security auto login
functionality
to run the bots and operates with a
locked screen allowing automated process
to run in complete privacy
let's look at the components of uipath
the first component we have ui path
studio
uipath robot and uipath orchestrator
let's look at them one by one this is
how a ui path studio looks like
ui patch studio is a user friendly
interface
inside the tool that allows user to
visually plan
and design various automation process
through diagrams using drag and drop
functionality
these diagrams are merely a structural
reflection of specific tasks
that must be completed this is the
activity
pane in the uipath studio it consists of
project
activities and snippets
this is the ribbon tab it consists of
saving options opening new files
debugging files recording screen
scraping data scraping and many more
we will explore this in the demo section
next we have output pane where output is
being displayed
and we have the properties pane where
the properties of each activity is shown
here
the next component is uipath robot after
you have built your process
the next move is to put into action in
the ui path studio
ui path robots are used to translate the
process into tasks
which are then executed these robots are
used to assign various tasks and carry
them out in the same manner as humans
but
without human interference when given
operation occurs on the computer
ui path robots are programmed to begin
executing tasks automatically
next we have uipath orchestrator the
orchestrator
is a web-based application in uipath it
has features like
deploying monitoring scheduling and
controlling automated bots and process
it's a centralized forum for managing
and controlling all software bots
let's look at the architecture of uipath
it consists of two sections the client
side and the server side
and the three layers let us look at them
one by one we will first look at decline
side
and the server side client-side ui path
components
are those that the user or developer can
communicate with directly
uipath studio uipath robot browser and
uipath agent are usually included
ui paths back and operation are
considered server side
the tasks and workflows that a user
produces are saved in the databases
uipath orchestrator chooses the
necessary function and the software
robots
to carry out the code's task the robot's
locks and statistics are stored in the
back end
locks are useful for analyzing robot
performance and detecting errors
in them the two elements comprise the
uipath robot
agent support for ui path and the
executor service for uipath
the agent support for uipath is a
service in ui path
that serves as the mediator between the
client side and the server side of
uipath
all of the information and data are
conveyed via the handler
messages are also logged into the
orchestrator before being moved to the
sql server
the service can be used to search all of
the currently available tasks in the
device tray
it also can change device settings and
start and stop the current task
execute the service for uipath in this
the software robots use this service to
carry out the tasks specified in the
windows session
now let us look at the three layers
first one is the presentation layer
this ui path components that are open to
the users
make up the client layer ui path studio
robots
browsers uipath agent and executors
for example a user or developer may use
these components
to design and create different tasks
that can be automated
computer robots are commonly used to
complete this task
the client layer is an another name for
the presentation layer
let us look at the service layer the
uipath's architecture's most
significant sheet the cloud layer shows
all server information
the ui path orchestrator is the most
significant part of the server layer
when the robots can perform the task the
entire project
is periodically uploaded to the server
within the aid of an orchestrator
the project is often carried out through
several structures
the orchestrator is in charge of the
whole band it keeps track of the project
development
schedule software robots for execution
and produces summary reports based on
the filtered parameter
it assists in the synchronization of
software robots so that they can
continue to perform routine tasks
it helps our project meet project
requirements service levels and
deadlines
thanks to its web-based management
system
now let us look at the persistence layer
database servers
make up the bulk of this sheet during
this layer
all of the robot's configuration
information is saved
users insert data robots assigned tasks
logging information and assets among the
other items into the orchestrators
configuration details furthermore
persistency layer is in charge of
keeping the log information
updated by the uipath agent services
elastic search is used to store these
locks the locks are primarily useful for
locating and correcting errors
process level data is usually saved in
relational database management system
such as
sql server this makes processing logs
from the vast volume of data a lot
simpler
hence the queues tasks are often taken
care by the persistency layer
let's look at some of the applications
of uipath
in sales in sales ui path is used to
generate invoice
this is an example of data replication
in action
both crm and accounting systems must
have the same sales details
bots can update accounting records
prepare and send invoices from the
appropriate email addresses instead of
manually replicating data
it is also used in keeping scorecards up
to date companies that do not have hr
and crm systems
integrated can use rpa boards to ensure
that crm adjustments are submitted to
scorecards in real time
allowing sales reps to track their
progress
it is used in crm updating a new
class of solution is evolving to
incorporate their email
call and other contact data into crm a
simple bot could be written to update
your crm records with customer contact
information
if you can't find a suitable solution
for using the crm systems
next it is used in banking in banking it
is used to check kyc
though dedicated kyc solutions are
evolving rba bots can be used to
automate portions of the kyc process
if your organization does not want to
use one
a case may be referred to an employee in
the event of an edge case that requires
human involvement
it is used in sanction of loans like
most document process
activities this method is appropriate to
rp automation
because complex business logic can be
embedded in bots
which can partially automate loan
decisions and the manual process that
follow
it is used in execution of trade rpa
bots may be useful in situations
where legacy systems are incapable of
storing complex limit orders
however this is more a band-aid solution
in the long run
switching to a sophisticated and
competent trading system
will certainly be a smart investment
considering how it could increase
trading and minimize trader workload
next it is used in healthcare in
healthcare it is
used for appointment scheduling the rpa
bot makes appointment for patient based
on their diagnosis
doctor availability location and other
factors such as financial statement
and insurance details it is used in
supporting analytics to improve patient
treatment
rpa bots may collect a variety of
medical information
rpa boards for example can use patient
data to a third party healthcare
analytics provider to provide more
reliable diagnosis
and better patient care without
violating any confidentiality
regulations
let's look at the benefits of ui path
increase productivity ui path automates
with quick speed and accessibility
consider an rpa board that allows a
worker to produce a monthly report in 20
minutes
instead of manually taking 4 hours the
company's productivity could increase as
a result of process automation
next we have high efficiency rpa
software
does not need a break it can operate 24
hours a day
a single rpa robot may replace two to
five full time workers
if not more robots can do the same
amount of work in less time or more work
at the same time than humans
customer experience in rpa adopted
business
routine and repetitive and boring tasks
are assigned to robots
allowing employees to focus more on
customer service
company may meet consumer needs with the
help of professional and knowledgeable
employees
highly secure there is no risk of
information leakage from one component
to another
because it performs single task as a
result data access is strictly monitored
and reported
cost effective ui path has minimal
operating cost
and more efficient use of it resources
let's look at the top companies hiring
ui part developers
infosys ibm deloitte
ey kpmg tata
tech mahindra and capgemini
let's look at the salary trends for ui
part developers
the average pay scale for a uipath
developer in india
is 5 lakh 45 000 rupees
ui part developer salary ranges from 362
000 rupees to 1 million
in usa the uipath developer salary
ranges from
58 000 to 107 000
and the average salary is 76 000
let's look at a demo consider a scenario
where you have multiple excel files you
want to combine the data in single file
in this demo we will merge two excel
files into a single excel file
and send it over an email let's create
automation to merge two excel files
using uipath
from here we can open a new project or
existing project stored locally or on
version control system
with the click we can open a new project
or create a new project from a template
uipath offers many templates depending
on what you're trying to do
for now let us start with a blank
project
so we'll open a blank project here
so we'll open a main workflow
then we'll go to new and select a new
sequence
we can do it using a flowchart as well
but for now i'll show you
doing a sequence so we'll open the
sequence and we'll name the sequence
since we are merging two files i'll name
it as
merging files
and i'll create it
so we'll go to the activities pane
firstly we need to drag and drop a read
csv activity
so search for read csv
so drag and drop read csv activity
since we are using two excel files so we
need to read csv activities
and read from the file we need to select
the file location
so we'll select the file location
sample csv file one
and at the file two we will select
another file location
sample csv file
at the output side we'll create a
variable
and name it as sl underscore file y
similarly for another csv
we'll create a variable and name it as
sl underscore
file 2.
so this much is done now we need an
assign activity
so we'll search for assign activity
so we'll drag and drop
assign activity has two parameters two
and enter an expression
so in the two we'll create a variable
name name it as merged
sl and
in the expression write an expression
say excel underscore
file1 dot clone
why are we using a clone function the
clone function creates a new data table
with same structure but does not copy
the data
oops it's showing an error here so
what's the error
so we need to assign the variable
type to be
system.data.data table
here we go error has gone
so after using the assign activity we
need to merge the data table so
we need merge data table activity so
search for merge data table here we go
drag and drop it
we need too much data table activities
so drag and drop
and specify the destination and source
here
the destination is the merged cell
and the source is the sl underscore file
one
for the first data merge table
similarly for second merge data table
destination remains same
source will change to sl underscore file
too
so this is done so next we need to drag
and drop a write csv file
right csv file creates an output file in
which you want to merge the two files
so search for
write csv here we go
drag and drop it
so choose the path create the file so
you can see there is no output file here
so we'll create the output file now
which is an empty file
so output dot csv
so we have created an output file
so right from we'll write it as merged
cell
we need the data from merged excel
[Music]
so the output file is created so now we
need to send the file over and mail
so for that we need to drag and drop a
get password activity
so we'll search for get password
activity
there we go drag and drop it
and once you get this get password
activity enter the password here
enter your password email id password
so there is a prerequisite when you use
get password
to receive a mail go to your google
account
in google account go to your security
option and in security there is an
option called less secure app access
turn that on i'll repeat turn on the
less secure app access
okay once the get password is done
go to the results section in the results
section
right click and create a variable name
it something may be sss
so i've created a variable there
so we need a last activity now that is
smt mail message smtp
mail message drag and drop it
so in the host port and enter this
server
so the server you have to enter it as
smtp
dot gmail all should be in the double
quotes
smtp.gmail.com
and enter the port number as 580
and enter your email id here which is
your own email id i'll enter my
once you enter the email id enter the
password
what we had created
so that's done so enter the email id
here
enter the subject whatever you want
so i will enter it as merged data
most excel files
enter the body
so we'll attach the file
so what is the file which we are
attaching
so we are attaching the output file what
we have named it as
output dot csv file
so that's it we'll run the program we'll
run the code
sample execution has started
and within the 10 seconds sample
execution has ended
so we'll go and check if we have
received the mail
so this is my email id
here we go we have received the email
here let's open this
let's open the output file
here we go you can see the data is being
merged
and if you go to the file where the
documents were stored here you go these
were the two files
the sample file one and sample file two
and this is the most file which was
created
let me show you the sample file 1
and sample file 2.
so this is the sample file 1 with 10
rows
and this is sample file 2 which also has
10 rows
so this is file 2 with 10 rows and file
1 with 10 rows
and here we go this is the output file
which has both tent and rose merged here
here we go it is sent over and made
so that's it it was an example
a demo for better understanding of
uipath
so with that we have reached the end of
this video like and share it if you
found it interesting
thank you for being here keep learning
and stay tuned to simply love
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel
and click here to watch similar videos
to nerd up and get certified
click here